all right ben it's my first day here do
you have any advice for me so
here's the thing never go in the
dressing room when knowles is in there
he has this
horrible habit i'm not lying to you of
just taking off his shirt randomly
and it is a terror to everyone
surrounding him in general stay away
from knowles i mean like 100
i will stay away from michael knows in
the dressing room and always and always
perfect
if you were famous for something else
what would you be famous for i'm an
excellent whistler
really yes come on ben you gotta do a
little bit oh well i mean i've been
having worse
i mean what you want to hear are you up
to
that's not even my weirdest skill my
weirdest skill is that i can actually
play these things on my cheeks
what what
[Music]
how did you realize you had this talent
i have no idea
i was in a fight one time somebody was
just hitting me in the face and suddenly
song popped out and i was like oh wow
that's kind of interesting i feel like
my whistling's pretty good too though
yeah that was myth if you could add
anyone to mount rushmore who would it be
and why first of all i hate mount
rushmore i think matt rushmore is an
idol i don't like idols
so have a very calvin coolidge feeling
about mount rushmore kevin coach was
very divided about
mount rushmore which is why i put calvin
coolidge on mount rushmore i probably
put donald trump just so i could see if
the left tries to tear it down oh my god
well i mean would that even be a
question yeah it'd be very i mean they
would tear it down but like how watching
them try to do it because usually they
just you know put ropes around the
statues and pull them down
it just would be fun to watch it as an
olympic event millions of people come
and claw at the rock with their fingers
so like i think that that is the best
thing we can do for society it would be
a fun game
to watch what was the worst job you ever
had i worked at a law firm immediately
out of law school that job was so bad
that when i quit that job
i went into the senior associate and i
said i'm unhappy
i hate this i'm depressed i just picked
up a mortgage and just was about to get
married
and my wife was like you need to leave
you hate this so cause she's a great
wife it was him and another senior
associate the second senior associate is
like why are you leaving
i explained all my reasons and after i
explained he goes you know you're
totally right maybe i should leave this
is a terrible job
and so it turned into the senior
associate trying to convince both of us
to stay
yeah and then i ended up in the boss's
office and i was explaining why i was
leaving and he was like
you just understand that you're never
going to make as much money as you make
right now
i've been wanting to send my tax returns
for at least a decade i can't think of a
single job but i would be like oh my god
it was so terrible it sucks so i think i
just suck because i'd like to work
if you could have someone like a
personal assistant follow you around all
the time what would you have them do
okay so i do and let me just say i don't
handle anything in my own life as
everyone who works at the daily wire
knows i have to be steered around like a
small child
from place to place they carry me to the
car like a baby they strap me into the
seat
i don't know i guess i don't know uh get
me
i'm really big into green juices so just
like perpetually just have fresh green
juices i hate to say that because it
sounds so hollywood
it does really kale kale is actually
really good
even kale like to eat kale kale salad i
i actually like kale it's like that
weird hollywood
no one likes kale this is a lot it's so
good i don't have it i'm like pierce
have you even like baked
even baked kale baked kale it's really
good every way you can have kale it's
actually delicious if it were that good
i'm embarrassed to say this
that good then for that people would
have been rich if they had much kale
that's not the way that it works what
was your favorite toy
and or hobby growing up reading i didn't
really
do toys so much how about you i was
really good at pogo sticking
pogo stick yeah like i'm like the pogo
stick and the hula hoop champ
hula hoop that would be my favorite toy
i could literally i could hula for hours
if you could live anywhere in the world
for a year where would it be easily
japan
uh i know it's so bizarre i have a thing
about japan i just i've always since i
was a kid i just am sort of fascinated
never been there japan
no but my it's a big leap just living
there i know i know but my husband's
sister lives there
she's lived there for 10 years she's a
missionary there so we're going to go
soon and i just feel like
i feel like it's just a cool culture i
don't know that's cool i know you
well israel obviously yeah there's
kosher food where else is there
food there's nothing we're gonna make
you pick another country besides israel
besides israel
uh italy italy spectacular ben shapiro
in italy i like it italy's great i'm
gonna tell michael knowles
well if noel's there i won't go pet
peeves
loud gum chewers i'm just like please
stop please stop please stop make it
stop you
feelings what's the best piece of advice
you've ever received
so my fourth grade teacher miss gennetti
she really dropped a heavy a heavy bit
of knowledge on me
i was reading these very advanced books
and everything and uh she and she said
to me
don't let potential be written on your
tombstone oh
like that is eight that's it that's
heavy stuff for like um for like a
really young
for that yeah yeah and i was like that's
really good advice i love that is good
advice
oh i love it don't let potential be
written on your team mine is definitely
that you are the average of the five
people that you spend your most time
with
and you will become the average so it
became a way for me to rinse my
friendships
that's a really that's a good piece of
advice i was like oh you're bringing
down my average man
so that is a really good piece of advice
the zombie apocalypse is coming who are
the three people you want on your team
not ben shapiro correct i would
definitely say
don jr because he just is always outside
it looks like he's surviving you know
for no reason
um taking my husband and the third
person would be hillary clinton because
you have to throw someone
to the zombies so you can get a head
start i mean hillary's a killer uh
i feel like hillary might survive which
is good because she'll kill the zombies
it's true you're ahead
for me i mean you you have to take your
spouse here's the problem there are
three people
and i have three kids so now you're not
sophie's choice so this got really dark
incredibly quickly if we're just talking
about like who would help me survive
i'll take jackal willing i'll take rogan
trying to think of a third
[Music]
what celebrity would you be super
nervous to meet
honestly i have a really tough time
thinking of celebrity i'd be super
nervous to me
i'm vladimir putin because he's a
murderer i say the only celebrity i'd be
super nervous to me and i it's not it's
a different type of nerd would probably
be the queen
because it's just i don't know she's
just been around
i gotta learn the curtsy and she's a
racist
yeah exactly so that makes it that you
should be nervous exactly
what fictional character do you wish you
could meet mystique from x-men did you
see x-men i did see x-men no one else
the daily wire has seen x-men and i was
like how do you not know who mostika's
and everyone was looking at me and they
were like
and i had to show them so i was like
[Music]
i mean i i feel like that might not be
as evocative as you think it is
like if you made those motions i
wouldn't have gotten there a lot of
characters
you're just going to keep doing it or
yes because i need you to acknowledge
that i look like mystique a little bit
i mean
i mean you do but you have to kick me
which fictional character
would would i want to meet you gotta go
class with the classics atticus fence
probably
yeah he seems like a classy dude i could
see him hanging out with mystique
what songs you have completely memorized
other than this is a weird question
because i have tons of songs memorized
obviously like probably maybe one people
wouldn't expect is like i'm very into
the sound of music i'm i was a huge
musical person are you a musical person
okay i'm a huge what are your music when
it comes to musical sound and music
being number one
by the way like i watched it on repeat
when i was a kid and the irony of that
is i had no idea what it was about
so like it's like literally when i got
ultimately i realized was i was like
this is
so sad because it's so sad i mean it has
a good ending but sound of music
mary poppins i loved when i was a kid i
wouldn't say it's like the best musical
when i was a kid i really loved changing
bang bang yeah that's a fun movie yeah
it was a fun movie have you ever we have
to get into some sondheim you're getting
like sweeney todd
yeah yeah it's hardcore i only know
susan utah because i think in high
school they did it as a play and i
watched it then
but i'm like very into musicals okay so
we'll get into sweeney todd tweeny's
great my husband's into operas though
family took me uh to two operas actually
i saw um
the barber of seville oh okay that's
good stuff that i can't remember hey
rossini if a criminal turns himself in
should he get the reward money yes but
then he should have to pay it to the
victim
but why why i mean he's a reward because
he technically fulfilled the terms of
the contract
as a lawyer let me tell you that if you
fill the terms of the contract
then consideration has been approved and
therefore you should receive the money
but the money should then go to your
victim yeah i mean if he says like i
turned myself in
he actually shouldn't be told how to
spend it either but he should also then
get sentenced for the crime right i mean
do you want to incentivize him to turn
himself energy do not want to intensify
them into terms
exactly i'm okay with them getting the
reward money then we yeah i mean i
totally agree with you all right does
pineapple belong on pizza
absolutely not it's a very easy question
to answer really
yeah are you like did you support barack
obama or did you vote for him okay well
then the answer is no
i will go for um jalapeno and pineapple
you are outnumbered at the a wire so you
know you're the only person that feels
that way
is a hot doggy sandwich it is not a
sandwich correct it's not a sandwich yes
yes you are my friend in the daily wire
okay michael knowles he needs to be
fired i know i've heard you've heard
this
no okay no you shocked me i'm shocked
shocked he needs to be fired i just i'm
going to leave that of course he needs
to yes i've only been here a few days
because of that question yeah he just
he's got this whole hot dog there
it's really sloppy that's stupid it's
closer to a taco than it is to a
sandwich it's
thank you i said literally the taco
thing i was like a taco it's not a
sandwich it's like
thank you so much and also matt walsh
said this but
that's just incorrect i was
fundamentally upset thank you thank you
we have to debate them on that
all right we nailed that that was
[Laughter]
[Music]
amazing